after More Than A Century of long-term
population growth the state of
California is now officially predicted
to stagnate California today has about
39 and a quarter million people a decade
ago that number was predicted to grow to
53 million by 2060. just three years ago
that prediction was adjusted down
significantly to 45 million and last
week the California Department of
Finance adjusted the prediction down
once more to 39 and a quarter million
the same number that we have today which
means that if the trend of prediction
adjustments keeps up it's likely that
California will die not of mere
stagnation but of mass Exodus